we still got meetings we still coming in
doing walkthroughs uh studying focus so
it really doesn't change anything a lot
hasn't changed but the thoughts are
changed almost definitely that's the
first thing i noticed when i got in here
uh i thought that i was late for me as i
look up i had an extra five minutes so i
was good so um that's the only thing
that's really changed like i said the
approach of the players and coaches are
also the same so you save yourself for
fines almost definitely
oh boy they're still having a good time
in jacksonville now that vp of football
operations tom coughlin is gone they set
the clocks back five minutes because you
know the coughlin rule if you're not
five minutes early for a meeting you are
late for the meeting that is now gone
because coughlin is gone and look we
talked about this a lot yesterday big
cat my biggest problem with this is the
guy was leaving anyway and i think and i
was i was told that he was going to
announce next week that week 17 was it
for him
they didn't give him a chance to walk
away with any any shred of his dignity
the guys won two super bowls right he
he's a guy who's potentially going to be
on the list for hall of fame candidates
once he's done and once the five years
go by they just should have let him walk
away i think if they would have gone to
him wednesday and said hey
it's over we'll let you resign or retire
today but it's over today they didn't do
that i think they should have
well uh to quote my
co-host on pardon my take they fired him
on coughlin time they fired him a little
earlier
but in seriousness mike like the fact
that they did this i think it shows just
how bad it had gotten with all these
grievances grievances and players
getting fined and i listened to what you
said i think yesterday but doug marone
will most likely keep his job so i think
making this change and letting everyone
know that this was the change that
needed to happen and the rest of the the
program so to speak is okay for next
year
i think that's a good thing to do i
think that if you were going to
fire doug maron in the gm as well then
maybe you do the whole house cleaning
week 17 end of week 17 but because those
guys might keep their job and it seems
like they will uh firing tom coughlin a
little early and sending a message is
the right thing to do and i think it's
the smart thing to do so i totally
disagree with you
i believe they will but no my point is
my point is you just let him walk away
just let him leave now you don't have to
have the pound of flesh and and all
those grievances right all those legal
fights the jaguars supported the jaguars
fought the jaguars incurred legal fees
they didn't have any internal debate
where they said you know what we should
let this go we should settle this they
fought it tooth and nail and the day
they lose all of a sudden they got rid
of they got to get rid of tom cough and
that's what i didn't like
and if you're gonna do it let him walk
away just let the guy walk away no mike
it makes sense though because it
essentially became the front office
coaching staff versus the players when
you get tom coughlin you might say it's
not right but i understand the move
because what they're doing is they're
sending a clear message that tom
coughlin was the problem tom coughlin
was the one who was spearheading these
grievances and these fines and we're
getting rid of him and we're becoming a
player first organization we're going
back to that i think that's why they did
that and it makes sense in my mind
yeah you get a dog that has a record of
biting people and then you're surprised
when the dog bites people that's
basically what it came down to for the
jacksonville jaguars all right true or
false time we're we'll get there
eventually and uh we played all that
we've had this discussion because the
first topic for true or false is this
true or false tom coughlin is done
working for any nfl team
oh
i would say
false because doesn't it seem like tom
coughlin will get that sweetheart
coaching search uh captain of the
coaching search that teams do that i
love whenever they're like hey we're
going to put together a group to try to
find our next head coach we're going to
bring in ernia corsi and tom coughlin
and pay them a million dollars to go uh
find one of their friends and whoops
friends or family members yeah we just
hired john fox again so
he'll have some set set up like that
right like a consulting so so not an
official title a long-term title but i
think he will be in and around some team
as maybe a consultant
yeah you know but usually it's former
gm's that get those gigs they don't hire
former coaches to be the consultants and
they shouldn't hire former coaches to be
the vp of football operations because
you can't expect a guy who's been a
coach for decades to quit acting like a
coach and that was the other problem
whether it's bill parcells mike holmgren
who had that gig in cleveland for a
while or coughlin a guy who's coached
for years and years and years and years
is now supervising the coach he's going
to want to second guess the coach he's
going to want to micromanage the team
because he's fundamentally a coach i
think he's done i think he's going to
retire and i think he's going to walk
away although it would be nice if there
was someone the fact that he did not get
to leave on his own terms could make him
inclined to try to have some sort of
final act that goes better than
jacksonville but i just don't think he's
going to have the opportunity i think
the way it went in jacksonville is going
to keep other teams from having anything
to do with tom coughlin all right true
or false carson wentz is the best
quarterback right now in the nfc east
oh
with back injury is what we're saying
i'm gonna say
oh man i'm gonna say true i'm gonna say
true because carson wins i think if he
had the same
type of uh
guys around him that dak prescott has i
think he would be we'd be talking about
a very different carson wentz he has had
a completely ravaged offensive line
weapons he's throwing to greg ward and i
don't even know what the other guy's
name is it's a they're like creative
players in madden at this point
if you're carson white
there's not much you can do other than
get out there and give it your best and
i would still if you if you gave apples
to apples
and they both had the exact same skill
positions around them i'd take carson
once over dak prescott
hey and you know i've said this recently
and i know you're going to disagree with
me because jared goff is one of your
friends but if you put carson wentz on
the rams and jared goff on the eagles
the rams would be in the mix for the one
seed right now and the eagles would be
four and 12. or on the path to four and
twelve i think really mean thing to say
but it's the truth it's the truth all
right uh i agree right now carson wentz
is the best quarterback in the nfc east
because of the dak prescott shoulder
injury and i'm very concerned about what
that means for the cowboys on sunday
they're saying all the right things as
we would expect them to what are they
going to do come out and say we're
screwed of course they're going to say
all the right things let's see how he
plays when it's time to get rolling late
afternoon on sunday true or false it
will be harder for mitchell trubisky to
score on the chiefs than it will be for
patrick mahomes to score on the bears on
sunday night football on nbc
i'd say true i think i i mean i i said
it in the segment before but the chiefs
defense has been a lot better and i
think that they uh you know last year
the chiefs defense it felt like it
wasn't a question of if just when it
would fall apart and you would see it
you know even in the afc championship
game when when they would get when the
patriots were converting those third and
tens and it was essentially the same
play over the middle to julian edelman
every single time this chief's defense
has a little more edge they have a
little more playmakers and they can get
they can get to the uh quarterback more
so i think that it's going to be not
easy for mitch trubisky it's not the
chiefs defense from last year
when they play on sunday night
here's the thing about the chiefs
defense over the last four games all
victories by the chiefs and i agree with
what you said earlier we aren't paying
attention to the chiefs the way we
should we kind of roped them off during
the patrick mahomes injury and when they
lost it home to the colts and texans in
back-to-back weeks they are a dangerous
team heading into the postseason they
are the one team in the afc that i would
give a very good shot at beating the
ravens in the postseason and mahomes
told me after that game last week when
they only allowed three points to the
broncos in the snow the defense has a
swagger now tyron matthew at practice
frank clark at practice chris jones
practice mahomes senses it he senses it
on game days they have that you know and
we said before the season the chiefs
defense just needs to get a little bit
better and early in the year it looked
like it was a little bit worse but it's
come around and they are better than
they were last year and i think it's
going to make it harder for trubisky to
score and it's going to make it harder
for anybody to score on the chiefs when
they play in the postseason do you agree
with my assessment that the chiefs are
the the first team you would think of in
the afc that has a shot at taking down
the ravens if they cross paths in
january
yes i mean they are the forgotten team i
you did kind of just steal that from me
in the same show but yes i would say
sorry i've been saying it all week i
don't trust the texans on the road
and i don't
i
actually no i'm gonna throw that out i'm
gonna still take the patriots second
time for bill belichick because he's
gonna have this special he's gonna
somehow solve lamar jackson mike i'm not
saying he's gonna solve lamar jackson
but we we have spoken about this what
has bill belichick done what are the
what are the pelts on the wall the k gun
the rams greatest show on turf if
there's one guy in the world who can
figure out how to game plan against what
we are seeing with the baltimore ravens
and how great they have been i would
take bill belichick so
you know the chiefs could maybe win a
shootout with the ravens but if you had
to ask me if i'd put my life on one team
to beat the ravens i think it's still
the patriots
when you say pelts on the wall it
reminds me the first time that that
phrase came up when sims was on the show
and he was very confused because he
thought the phrase was pellets on the
wall and he had no idea what that meant
so uh chris sims doesn't have drew brees
in his top ten
i thought chris he's got him at ten nine
or ten
i was i had a little heart palpitation
on whatever day it was because i thought
maybe he had passed away because he was
trending on twitter no he was trying to
start
true or false ryan tannehill versus drew
brees is the best quarterback matchup of
the week ooh
um poof that is tough
i'd say you know what if we're doing
present tense ryan tannehill 2019 sure
why not let's throw this in there uh i
still would probably put actually if
we're doing present tense it might be
your boy mike it might be kirk cousins
and aaron rodgers right because both
those guys aaron rodgers hasn't had a
great statistical year
but if you still had to put your money
on a quarterback he's up there and kirk
cousins has had a great statistical year
so it's either this one or the monday
night game i'm gonna actually go
false so switch it up for me false
i still think desean watson and jameis
winston is the most fascinating matchup
but maybe because of the injuries to the
buccaneers receivers that takes enough
away from it look tannehill and breeze
playing outdoors this is a huge game for
both teams titan's still trying to get
into the playoff mix and they'll know by
sunday whether or not the texans lost to
the buccaneers if the texans lose it's a
much bigger game for the titans because
their path to the division is more clear
and the saints have that path to the
number one seed and they're going
outdoors after a huge win this is a
saints team that has not been blowing
people out can they continue to play
like they did on monday night or is it
just one of those nights where
everything lined up perfectly for drew
brees and the saints and and they won't
be able to replicate it especially
outdoors i think there was a 53 chance
of rain for nashville when i checked it
yesterday if it rains if it's a little
cold it's a different vibe altogether
for the saints but it should be a great
game i don't know i'll go false as well
whether it's vikings packers with rogers
and cousins whether it's the game on
sunday uh whether it's trubisky and
mahomes on sunday night who knows but i
think that there are better quarterback
matchups this week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports